hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to alien isolation I
apologize for being incredibly tired in
the last episode but I had to record or
else I wouldn't have been able to get up
a video at all that's what I have to do
these taste but I don't mind it at all
because playing game at night there just
isn't that bad hello creatures you heard
the lady
let's go oh I said the creature was
nearby I didn't even understand that how
was I supposed to know that they were
not hostile wait come back isn't there
safety in numbers do you actually want
to run away right now could you please
be my friend because no one else will be
okay good idea
clear
don't talk to anyone
okay well that all sounds good but I
still got a few gallons of napalm that
are shaking around my back is that gonna
be a problem when the monster is trying
to get to me because I really don't want
to say hi to it just yet actually I kind
of do because I want to blast it in the
face with my steamy hot okay so I gotta
go up there to open it somehow I mean I
have been here before but well the first
time I came through one I didn't exactly
know how to play the game in two I
didn't exactly know where I was going so
hopefully I'll be able to get back here
and miss any secrets that I may have not
gotten just yet I know that someone said
that there was an easter egg where I get
the maintenance check but I don't think
that was here I think I got that before
although I may be I will go back again
there they'd be really cool these people
have told sevastopol's do for the
scrapheap right I just got a message
from Ellison and Sikhs and accounts can
we fix the hand dryer in the restroom
can we hell next time one of these
[ __ ] requests come through send them
right back you got it boss expecting an
order from all stations that should have
arrived by now I usually get several a
week but there's nothing can someone
check my coms unit cannot afford to lose
business
Pookie Dookie Aurore seek sentence now
cuts his losses abandoned Sebastopol
okey dokey oh I can do that what the
mouse wheel I did know more stuff about
the business that I do not know but I
need to open the door
then the supply storage maintenance
access I'm not going okay whoa whoa whoa
whoa you're not evil yet I know you want
a taste of it breath cuz you will get a
taste of it you'll get a face full of it
still creepy I don't care if you're not
trying to kill me actively I still don't
like you okay so this is a new area
there's a body bag that's handy and
bonding agent stop this is someone's
camping ground right among the bags of
the dead good here you know if this was
dead space the Necromorphs would have a
feeding
that's right that's right who's the
badass where's me I'm a badass that you
are freaking [ __ ] yeah least you won't
fire I knew there had to be a reason I
was lugging around all this flame fuel
[Music]
but you just got caught in the crossfire
I can't really be helped about that
who's your fault
you ain't agonize me you brought this
upon yourself I hope I'm going the right
way right now that looks fancy and big
are you still really I'm trying not to
run you just make me want to distracted
me so that they could get to me the
stupid guy got in the way of my flame
blast how else was I supposed to get
away from the guy
I tried no whatever so anyway I'm gonna
get back to it I'm actually not gonna
die this time because I'm not dumb I
just got excited about the fire walking
fire it's like magic man if I had a
flamethrower back in medieval times I
would I would be in jail for murder
because I'll be doing terrible things
come on oh I forgot that he could hear
me here run away yo dose that's right
big baby
know about it I got the power now I have
a feeling he's good you got it I'm gonna
seal this guy in mass [ __ ] there's no
override on that one so I'm just gonna
make my way upstairs I'm gonna forgo the
items that a guy I'm gonna take this
nice and calm I don't know if I need to
crouch just yet because I do happen to
have a giant walking piece of fire come
on dude I came here to do whatever the
hell that is
Sammy's not gonna sneak up on me yeah I
don't know where I am
oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] this is bad
[Applause]
back off
oh god I'm chewing through way too much
of the stuff I'm gonna take this calmly
and quietly from now on I cannot risk
running out of flamethrower fuel just
yet I need to be able to get through all
of this first first and foremost get
through everything then burn him alive
okay not important out of horn right now
you guys can read that pause the video
if you want to read that okay you got it
you got it good enough we're gonna get
going because I cannot cannot deal at
the moment okay so now I need to see off
the stairwell I already did that
seal the creature inside the server farm
okay will do so basically it's gonna be
chasing me no matter what I do right Oh
was that the that's right come on come
on yeah run away maybe I was reading up
on a hole I was reading got to put on a
whole bunch of others
that's right run buddy
finally I have a way to fight him so I'm
guessing that moving quietly is not that
important right now except that he won't
exactly know where I am
he's gonna try to do this quickly so I
can get through it before he comes back
okay okay you guys can pause if you want
to read that I'm just seeing if there's
like a door control haha use it doesn't
know exactly where I am yet does he damn
it
you gonna do I think that bought me some
time because now I'm assuming that he
lost me so he doesn't know where I am
right now which works to my advantage
correct she's gonna loop it's all he's
gonna do how do I seal off the stairwell
by the way no idea Oh over there okay I
got it I got it
okay so we use Patrol oh there's no need
for that to have been squishy I'm gonna
I'm gonna wait nomina oh there's gonna
be he's gonna be right in front of you
Oh
like I do not wanna put oh just done it
by now screw it what do I do
yeah that's right okay no pirates gonna
come in here okey-dokey
now what okay so I got a lockdown server
hub in the reception corridor however
the hell I get to that assuming it's
another exit on the stairwell but I
don't know which one
where Z where Z God I'm so close I did
not know he was coming that way oh I am
NOT lost thank you dickbag okay how do I
get to I probably have to go down level
was probably door down there that I
passed by early on
oh those way too close way not cool mega
super odo not stand under event which
way do I go
dad where am I supposed to go I wasted
so much my ammo also dead
where do I go um got I swear I didn't
see anything up there I got to go back
up I guess maybe it's server hub
reception corridor locked down all
escape routes to the service farm before
sealing it inside okay so I'm assuming
that now I how do I get to it I did not
see another entrance up top so there
must be something down here oh god no
it's locked down so it's gotta be so
what you doing
thinking of sneaking up on me you floor
up
thank you for logging all of these
problems you douche
so I've been there but it's not exactly
locked down yet was there something else
in here that I needed to get to
I don't think so there wasn't another
door in here I'm sorry if I'm tumbling
around a little bit I need to find the
right way to go or else I'm gonna be so
screwed server hub reception oh right
there I did not see that I'm an idiot it
was right in front of me oh that was
probably the first one I did before I
died and I forgot that I needed to do it
again Oh what are you gonna do
oh we're gonna play this game again I
must sprint around a little bit you hear
that you hear that hear that
right back up me go right back into this
I go come on quit click click I think
you look like bunny okay
that was the last one right oh no I
needed to go in here and lock it inside
here that's right okay hello don't you
get here okay so that guy is just wait
if I see the Drule you know for a
perfect hunter you have one dead
giveaway get drool away too much I'm not
that tasty and maybe Ripley jr. is oh I
don't know that was there was there code
and one of the other things that I
didn't see locked it's got to be
something else here right got to be
something else
oh okay that's easy seven seven eight
nine
well then Ripley okay seven seven eight
nine you got it okay
yes I happened at our transmission
lately archiving I've done some ecliptic
to Pastor semester
really
[Music]
I'm almost out of flame what was I
supposed to do I I'm supposed to lock
down all escape routes enroute to the
server farm activate Ricardo's override
command I did that didn't I
so they did that how do i Oh what do I
do run this Oh hit that I'm sorry I
thought I needed to do something else
what are you doing okay bye see you
later
I didn't know I needed to run a program
just give me a little bit I am way I'm
cutting this way too close
initiate lockdown
you got it please let me through please
oh there we are over there
thank you sir can you help me find an
alien dude don't make me flame you
doesn't know I'm here
okay I'm going stealth mode now it's too
much
oh okay bye
where am I okay thank you Ricardo you're
a big help
I'm sure I'll do fine I'm all I'm out
I'm completely out of flint thorough no
I'm not just yet well I don't know how
to make more where am I going in here I
need to go down there go to the left I
need to make my way through here doesn't
know I'm here
no okay
this game is stressful I will tell you
that it is very very stressful I may run
out of it before I'm able to get rid of
him again god I'm getting texts I don't
have time for oh god damn it I almost
flamed you wait I don't need to know
anything I need to know when you're
gonna leave me the hell alone just back
off okay god this game is way too
stressful what's in there uh bye nothing
good where is this guy
we're gonna go okay so I need plasma
torch I need God I'm in the wrong spot
I'm almost there it's like a goddamn
maze I need to reload this thank you
very much I know I might be losing the
ammo but I'm not sure if that's how this
works in this particular game enough
Oh
pissing balls
what okay how am I still alive
you will shut the [ __ ] up I don't know
why I'm alive I thought I was done so
what the hell happened
okay let's try that again with less
stupidity over there come on come on
quick quick quick don't have time what
is oh that's the other one okay got it
got it right onto okay okay okay we're
fine
geez Oh God why why nerve gas I don't
have don't have enough for that thank
you cool I have more flamethrower though
oh yeah it's flamethrower oh no no no no
no no no okay I'll do it I'll do it I'll
do it oh crap
come on pick one or the other
okay come on come on come on come on
come on come on come on you know
[Music]
okay so all I gotta do is get out well
it's hard enough getting in just get out
I'll just be on my way
[Music]
that's a bps beep but hopefully it's
gonna lead him away from me
he's over there he's going for the beep
so I just got to get out of here right
just gotta you don't go more time on it
tie which way do I go both the doors
closed off that's what come on
what do I need to do I need to go
through there where where where lock it
down
come on come on come on my palms are
like so sweaty right now everyone bare
with me I know I'm not saying a lot but
I'm happy saying more than I think I am
but just bear with me for a frickin why
is this place not secured yet whoa God
you son of a [ __ ]
stop doing that Jesus why do I have to
be the one to do all this crap
Oh Oh bugs gasps I got to shut off the
gas I guess just don't do that but let
Bob up got old technology is bad air
purification needs yes I need door
access oh god it's either door access or
air purification kind of pull with this
I guess I got to get through it and then
I'll be able to open the door on the
other side with another hack module like
yes not seeing any spots for a possible
ambush okay ah this is what I'm supposed
to do maintenance yeah oh that's the bed
come on come on come on come on come on
come on no time no time no time in a bit
of a rush wolf okay hey Ricardo what did
you just leave me behind
I'm out of here
there's no
okay
this whole trapping plan oh I don't like
the finality of the way that you say
that it seems to have a lot of self
sacrificing involved that doesn't
involve yourself more of myself kind of
deal okay all right I don't know enough
fuel for this okay where am I going okay
so I need to go back down the elevator
over here not over there down that way
okay this way we'll need to go back to
the main elevator back to the dudes who
were there who didn't help me at all and
then ran off to save their own skin not
that I blame them and then I'm gonna
lead it somewhere else
thankfully I'm not being very cautious
so it doesn't necessarily know where
exactly where I am so maybe it won't be
able to follow me for a little bit now
give me some time to stay away from see
what else gonna craft
noisemaker the noisemaker I just got the
version two of it I guess that's better
or something I don't know is it noisier
it's got a bumped up base
I don't know how most of these work I
don't even know why I would need it
EMP mine or how I know to make that but
this is the future we're talking about
with Future Passed technology I don't
think that I lost my ammo when I
reloaded before but I'm hesitant to do
it again now because they got enough to
make him go away
maybe two times if I ration it right
he's got to hit him hard and fast with
bursts straight to the face splatter
napalm all over him
nice and slow nice and quiet and let's
not have any more of the working Joe's
but space Mon have any more the working
Joe's pop up at me please do not do that
hello working Joe don't pop up in me
whoa what do you mean I'm I'm gon I'm
gonna shoot you in the face so hard you
don't even know what's gonna happen oh I
get it
okay so somehow my shells disappear into
my gun I don't know how that works but
okay so how am I gonna go you may have
attracted some company that you don't
want
[Applause]
Oh can't say you didn't deserve that one
okay well that was your own dumb fall
you doof such a doof all of ever dying
this is like people constantly walk into
their own doom okay dad I realize I
shall rue the day that I run out of
napalm oh you know I kind of don't want
people to be shooting at me but I gotta
admit it's oddly convenient when they
just want to throw themselves to the
wolf
and die a horrible death oh wait I'm
going to the transit station right now
there's got to be is there different
elevator than where I'm going I can only
assume that's there but I don't recall
there being an elevator over there let's
just make our way down there and then if
it's not there I'm assuming it's
upstairs it must be up there like I'm
not how about that we give it I'm not
crazy am i am i I don't recall seeing an
elevator down on the first floor so
there must be something on the second
floor yeah I think is that
[Music]
yeah that's why he's guarding that over
there okay so if I can play this
accordingly if I can make a good throw
with a noise maker I might be able to
get him go all the way over there
but I don't want him to come to me this
way hopefully this oh crap he's gonna
come this way isn't this
oh my goodness yeah yeah what is that
that's weird whatever that is stab it
stab it with your Tina's pale okay never
mind someone try to interpret what the
hell is trying to say there and I'm not
weird
I swear stab him with your penis whoa
you didn't see nothing yes I knew oh ho
the quietest elevator in the world I did
a good thing I play the game well I'm
learning it's fun to learn weights I
mean Jim in there okay well that all
sounds fun good but how do I do what I
need to do I've got a job I'd rather not
have this job it's like the job at five
nights at freddys why in the world would
I choose this trying to find mommy ma
try to find my mom ah
Ripley senior needs to be found oh hello
who are you
this really doesn't feel right
no because you're ready to be eaten by
an alien you're just so I admit it
that's a pretty view I would I would be
staring at that dude that is a really
cool view you stop being so pessimistic
lady listen you're a beautiful creature
but you're standing with your back turn
to event you're probably gonna die you
don't have very good horror movie
instincts if it hasn't killed you yet
I'm shocked oh by the way I let it up
here did I mention that I totally let
the yeah I let it right here you might
be already be going crazy so you try to
get down here and you move your fat butt
around as quiet as you can you know how
hard it is to Crouch walk I'm not alone
Crouch walk for like 10 miles it's hard
and try it that's your latest workout
routine just do that for a little bit
you never have no idea is that
electrified
water in here okay
thanks weights we're giving away my
position I've got plenty of flashbangs I
need to use those necks cuz I have not
been using those and yes it is apparent
that I don't lose the ammo anymore so
that's good I don't know if that was
just for here but that's cool maybe that
was just the evil within I can't
remember a man playing both at the same
time they're kind of blurring in between
each other that's the security camera
isn't it
hello that's a fancy camera all righty
then I'm gonna wait for it to pass by go
under it and then be on my way so long
as that guy doesn't care that I'm here
what is that sound I do not like that
sound that is a very bad sound
environment that guy is not doing well
by the torch yay I got the special
addition to my torch here
I've got all sides afire whoa there's a
box I did not I keep missing these boxes
I need to find I need to be on a better
look out for malukas my point of view is
always gonna be very low unstable system
and camera feet turn off the camera feet
whatever the hell the unstable system is
I'll go for that okay
it did something over in the other
corner of the place I don't know if
that's gonna hurt me or hinder me plasma
torch push key
let's whoosh this goes much faster thank
you okay good enough for me God do you
think that would damage some of the
valuable intricacies of this electronic
but no this is the 80s sci-fi they're
all good oh oh god you're gonna make
you're gonna make me go through this
pitch black aren't you oh I should have
known there hasn't been a really dark
scene for a while now so yay okay see
general is that sound not liable for
your time remaining on Gemini personal
contracts okay eight eight nine seven
eight eight nine seven don't know what
that was going on here
I saw live okay I'm okay I'm okay I'm
okay I'm okay let's go let's go let's go
yeesh you she she she she she she she
alright eighty ninety seven eighty nine
seven it's that guy still alive
hopefully not okay I see what you're
doing there ain't no way ain't no way
I'm gonna fall for that eighty nine
seven also the noise noise might
actually be a bit of a giveaway huh what
how can
oh you're oh you're so sneaky oh you're
just a sneakiest oh I got a present for
you
[Music]
okay I need to use this I'm gonna run
out of flame I know I'm not doing well
on that front but he's being just a
little too aggressive for my day so I
need to circle back around that way
trickle the analysis breakers circuit
breaker okay so I'm gonna be very stiff
I'm going back into stealth mode right
now I just need to get through there
back into self mode right back into it
totally quiet
dammit I can't do the emergency override
from
[Music]
decided to run then they're okay no more
joking around I'm screwed I'm dead I'm
so dead beyond dead
well this pole place looks familiar I
don't know what horrible things await me
in here need to see I gotta use a
noisemaker wait over there
what was that good throw me thank you
thank me yeah that's weird huh nobody
knows nobody will ever know I just need
to save so that you don't murder me I
got action undo the things that I just
did but I'm gonna go up here now you'll
never know
you'll never know what's the noisemaker
we're Ripley jr. had got whoa god I
thought those were eyes oh six hundred
percent positive those were eyes please
tell me you can't climb that ladder oh
please tell me you can
it's gone ain't gonna do nothing to him
I don't even know if the stun baton will
do anything to em I think the only thing
that'll stop him is fire all right we're
okay we're okay
I'm completely out of fuel so I
shouldn't be sloshing anymore I'm so
dead
so dead I'm so dead I'm so dead I'm so
so so dead
what is in that jar you can't see me I'm
hiding I'm too stealth
oh god I'm not even supposed to be here
Oh butter go why did I do this why did I
choose to screw myself over okay there's
something I can cut through over there
but I don't if that'll be good for me
well what okay so he's not bothering me
just yet
[Music]
got there's no way to close that door
Oh God with you through your music
[Music]
and almost like it okay he's going back
up in damn good for this time being for
a little bit just for a little bit come
on come on come on come on come on need
to have the knowledge wait Oh two seven
four three
I don't know all these numbers 2 7 4 3 8
8 9 - I don't remember what the other
one was - 7 4 3 2 7 4 3
whatever oh right there ok
don't know [ __ ] you
now [ __ ] you
what's that it whatever fine you can be
that way
ion towards God how much stuff do I need
oh that sends out to the Nostromo wait
the Nostromo is that mine no that's how
my [ __ ] that's the old one even a stroma
mr. Oh is there any reason for me to go
in there no no no no way no no ok you're
fine
you're fine you're fine you're fine
nothing's happening oh the unstable
system okay I don't know what the
unstable system does but it doesn't seem
to hinder me anyway
whoa with me knocking everything over oh
I was supposed to go up here okay I
wasn't wrong I knew there was a reason I
was supposed to be here there'd be
something Oh
good blood oh no no no no oh god no you
son of a [ __ ] you're so sassy someone
died in there
okay that's one so I need to go now way
the hell over there wherever the hell
that is
just good for me we just grabbed what's
in here Oh looka I don't want to go in
the bloody vent thank you very much I'd
rather stay right here or things only
will probably kill me
oh that was loud come on come on come on
use your muscles there Ripley quiet
quietly func so far so good
back down at least the alien decided to
leave me alone for a little bit I need
to use a med pad okay fine let's do a
little Savi I know hostels are nearby
I'm very well aware of all that you know
it's weird this games is pacing it takes
me so long to complete objectives I
actually kind of like it better now that
I'm out of flamethrower fuel because it
brings back the threat and the threat is
really what makes this game terrifying
it's just like oh my god I'm dead like
all the time that's exactly what I want
out of this game so I'm very happy to be
rid of all my flamethrower fuel good ok
so I need to go down there
Oh piss Oh
Pass oh how do i oh pass ok I got a long
way to go back now there was something
down here that may be needed I'm gonna
go down and see if it's uh again why the
music why the music the music right now
poor you did don't seem dead dead
yeah you seem dead okay
wow I knew it you son of a [ __ ] oh good
lordy no no you son of a [ __ ] you just
did that to dick with me [ __ ] bag
all right break hurry said we're okay so
I can't do yet yet until I get to the
breaker but that definitely announced my
presence hello friend yeah yeah that was
a weird noise that I heard over there on
you should go investigate it over there
and stay the hell away from me yeah
weird huh
I got flamethrower I'm gonna try to
avoid using it but I got it
that's what's important yeah oh I see
so this is the core okay so this is the
corridor I saw ah this looks very
official all right so this is gonna
leave behind everything ooh
technology No oh god if he could follow
me in here I'd be very upset he's not is
he
you can't tani
I'd be the douchiest of the do she know
Hey
[Music]
okay how's my one time I'm gonna use the
flame throughout every sit again I
promise
totally promise cuz I'm a good little
boy my good little boy who eats his
potatoes
what can I just smash that why do I have
to deactivate it at that stupid power
conduit ding come on come on come on
no time no time no time always in a rush
always in a rush to move very slowly
whatever the hell the unstable system is
that's what gets got I'm assuming that
the unstable system is what's actually
distracting him and not making him go
right for me all the time at least
that's my assumption because every time
I do it he seems to go away for quite a
little bit where the hell am i oh okay
then well that didn't help me at all on
my way back him away down to the down to
the decontamination room breaker switch
walking fast moving fast so I'm gonna
switch it now I got to go back all the
way back so many loop-de-loops that are
gonna make so many panics moment I get
out when I'm face-to-face with the
monster damn alien damn damn alien damn
son of a [ __ ] damn damn alien damn
piece of [ __ ] ass alien damn poopy buddy
alien
and a million I'm gonna go back in here
climb up climb up climb up climb climb
climb climb climb where's your back fine
what the [ __ ] are you [ __ ] me there
we go god damn it oh god I thought he
was right behind me
you son of a [ __ ] you can't do that to
me I'm in the panic situation you can't
make the thing not work for me
son of a [ __ ] oh my hands are so sweaty
right now I'm good though I'm having fun
playing video games I don't know if I
looted this plenty of stuff I need to
craft up some more smoke bomb that was
actually pretty useful I probably need
to use that more I mean I have so much
scrap yeah I mean there's so many things
that I'm crafting up that like I don't
know when I'd ever run out I need a pipe
bomb though maybe I could blast that son
of a [ __ ] - he'll never have to deal
with him for the rest of the whole game
this is one one monster one monsters
doing all this [ __ ] to us to us I
mean to me I meant us the whole station
I feel like I'm living in this place now
that I have a deep connection with these
people in here
so yeah us us me and refugee
[Music]
only me I'm just gonna save and then I'm
trigger and then we all know I don't
worry about me don't worry about me
kachunk I sure wish I could save my life
all the time by the way my wrist looks
very odd when it does that because it
just kind of splays out at an angle and
it's like nothing to do with the joint
oh you sack of crap not just yet give me
two more seconds just give me some time
buddy
[Music]
okay well okay he's coming gone come on
come on come on what is that it sounds
like it's breathing I don't like that
[Music]
okay now what okay now what now what
what was the point of all that okay
are you hostile oh oh I see okay good
good technology working with technology
to make sure that technology works good
good
now what
that's fancy what did it do dude why was
that like on molten lava what
[Music]
maybe I'm not understand I think I'm
supposed to be doing something with this
because it's like there's like an error
going wrong the things aren't
cooperating
oh hi something's going on that I need
to do but I don't I don't know what it
is restore access to distribution inside
Gemini exoplanet Solutions once inside
locate the freight elevator and take it
to project kg 3 for 8 initialize the
distribution car that's what I did but
he's doing the thing
I gotta cut that closer yeah it's all
broken down over there son up here what
am I doing wrong wrong I can't get to
that because he's there maybe you gotta
kill him that seems like the proper
solution I got a killer
[Music]
oh boy as soon as a shot let me just
stun baton that's what he's not awesome
what am I doing wrong
he must have been like deactivating the
power every time it popped up because
he's a dick drag no whatever whatever
whatever whatever else
whatever gets poopy poopy wasting so
much time trying to get all that to work
no it had to be how about I just smack
you in the face now would that be
appropriate
I'm just gonna do this what oh you we
set a charge [ __ ] yeah you're gonna die
extra hard for that that's right get
down
busty good giving mix it cuz you knew I
was a grand all right I got flan throw
this time
[Music]
run away a little baby okay I don't have
time for you right now I don't have time
for you
I got places to be yup Dale you don't
want to help go suck a gong okay so I
need to go get the freight lifts so I
either go
okay I need to play ring around the
rosey with this dude
yeah it's not authorized in any facility
kind of an alien attack going on maybe
she'd be more concerned about that than
me the updated map I need to go that way
safety I get it you're a douche okay
well this looks ominous we're fine we're
fine fine everybody's got that go the
wrong way
Wow it was like the only way to go oh
I'm supposed to go the other way he was
blocked off I guess I should use the med
kit as wanting me to do that apparently
yeah yeah come on come on lie down
supplies here I can't go through there
because it's all blocked up there must
be another access point no there's not
there's got to be a way to move this
otherwise would be no point how do I
move it how do I move it whoa
where where where why and where okay
whatever I'm not gonna ask questions
right now there's something there there
is something important about this that
what I need
ah there we go gotta gotta gotta gotta
gotta gotta okay dad moved it that did
it
gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta got it I'm
good I'm good I'm good
well this looks dangerous and scary okay
it's a really steamy in here at least
it'll be good for my pores okay
hi box I need another safe pretty soon
air purification more important than
lighting right now
[Music]
once again
oh yeah you better run you better run
so do him the next time I need to say
point and now like right now I'm gonna
panic yeah I don't want to do any of
this again it's been so long since the
save point okay okay that's the wrong
way I went the wrong way damn it damn it
went the wrong way it's at a save point
no that was a power box Oh God doesn't
show the same point on the map okay I'm
okay so I need to go back I need to go
down I need to go through the bottom
floor instead of going up and then I can
get to the elevator and then I can get
the hell out of here
Oh God come on
yeah oh I'm going so the wrong way now
[Music]
there's another one way over there
what's with all these weird noises uh
oh oh I guess I could have taken that
tunnel in between the two of them that
might have been a little bit easier than
the way I went but oh well who cares
good golly this whole game is just a
stress nightmare always in forever I
didn't know I was supposed to go through
your or else I would have gone there the
first yes that's what I need that right
there that is exactly what I need so I'm
gonna go in there I mean just fine where
the hell does that go oh I could have
gone around ah whatever whatever
whatever don't care don't care don't
care oh baby oh oh Jesus balls what in
the world yeah okay so I locked that
poor lady in there with her wait I made
it her him I think so of course it is
it's got a personal vendetta against me
why wouldn't it be after me where's a
save point gimme a save point
don't be douchey Kimmie that save point
baby that's the same point oh thank you
thank you thank you think you think you
think you think you thank you okay
alright so I am officially done with
this part I'm going to continue this in
a little bit here thank you all so much
for watching and as always I will see
you in the next video
[Music]